the moment for me came after several
years of doing TV commercials in Chicago
hand-drawn I did the great SS guppy yes
I did do captain crunch and I was I was
the guy saying like I'm never gonna
leave drawn animation I loved the and
still continue to this day to be amazed
that almost every other art form in the
world you're in direct contact with your
art if you're singing a song you're
making that music now if you're
sculpting you're pushing clay around
animators are like blindfolded sculptors
we have to put our hands in our pockets
and then they take the blindfold off we
get to look at our animation and then we
want to change it they put a blindfold
back on and we have to kind of feel our
way through these keyframes so I had
decided that I was never going to do
computer animation and one particularly
long day working on a sansa belt slacks
commercial and we used to shoot on a
Bolex and take the we used to bucket
test we didn't have a dark room so we
would take the 16-millimeter and swish
it around in a bucket of dollar and
feels like the fly shoes did in the
1930s well I was a little Chicago studio
and so my fingernails are all burning
off from the like chemicals and this
this guy post effects who'd bought the
very first alias system which was
designed to be something an artist could
use he said please just come over and
look at it so I went over and I was mr.
curmudgeon about it and I built a brick
with four sections and I basically did
the flour sack test a classic drawn test
who can you make a flour sack of emotion
I built this little rectangle volume
with four sections and in about a half
hour I had set all the keyframes and
then I hit play and even back then in
1986 in a wireframe it played right away
and it felt like the closest thing to
not having to put the blindfold back on
and that aha moment of going wait a
minute I don't have to get my
fingernails burned off by harsh
chemicals to do animation and I can get
a feedback that means I can change it
quicker and see the result and get
closer to the core of what an animator
does craft a performance I got very very
excited and immediately offered to do
anything to to work for this guy and
then work very closely with alias which
eventually became my
was really the the sort of first
software that could do something more
powerful and more artists friendly it
was available to you know production
studio
you